hi there day 67 it's a Saturday
you know I woke up this morning well
first of all yesterday evening I had the
discussions with two Korean tutors at
Lincoln and I have kind of grabbed a bit
the end of one in the beginning of the
other put it up here because there were
some comments about I only speak to
girls and I do all the talking so I
tried although it's much against my
nature to let the other side speak more
and you can have a look at it before
doing that though and I'm not gonna put
up any subtitles those that understand
Korean can follow it those that don't
I'm sorry there's nothing of any great
significance being said there but you
know I woke up this morning and I said
jeez you know I really struggle in my
sort of ordinary conversation I struggle
with basic you know endings of verbs and
structures and suffer and I of course
look for words and stuff so I could know
I grabbed it here you know I could in
fact I was tempted to go and spend more
time with these basic patterns of the
language to try to kind of drill them
into me and I could spend my day
listening to the basic patterns of the
language which I did at the beginning
and which was very helpful
so I started leaving through this I just
can't do it anymore I can't do it then I
said to myself what I really what do I
really want if at the end of the 90 days
in other words 20-some odd days from now
23 days from now my spoken Korean hasn't
improved that much it really doesn't
matter that much to me it may cause some
people to say well you didn't really
achieve very much and so forth which is
fine and that's gonna be probably
accurate but I say to myself really I'm
motivated to understand more of Kim Jung
Hwa's podcast that's what motivates me I
now have two transcribers one is doing
the you know episode one to 30 and the
second one has now started out you know
pumping out transcripts for 30 you 31 32
33 and so eventually I'll have all 53 so
my motivation is to get to where I can
listen to these understand them
have all of the vocabulary are a lot of
the vocabulary that comes with that and
as I said before I know from experience
that in the long run I'll be better off
when I want to crank up my speaking I'll
be able to crank it up and I'll have you
know a solid base in the language so so
I think there is this sort of you know
how quickly do you want to get to where
you can speak well versus you know
putting your effort into building up a
sound or base in the language and of
course if I had unlimited time if I was
a full-time student at a university in
Korean Studies that I would do both but
you know I have to find the time to fit
my studies in so I'm gonna focus on
things that I enjoy doing and that I
know from experience in the long run
will be more beneficial so that's my way
of introduction and now you can look at
me struggling with the language bye for
now
town boom tongue gay Olympics
Hangul day oh yeah yeah yeah boom
don't cha don't cha 1902
uncommercial red truck olotele a manual
Tunica da cunha money the cool Togepi in
pink over a plastic JAMA chinampa
short attack are you taught to tone it
up
mmm toy yeah yeah okay
your job your job to go ski Kim no to go
Sochi is all could one day to God think
I skate the mmm have you said
t-bob jaebum tittle judging system to go
toyou he also me by tomorrow don't
understand till tomorrow huh knocks on
door Kim Cahill tail tone salsa Roche
the diva capable somebody how do you say
quit up are the rules
coochie-coochie you know something honey
sandy I don't
Adam rebel okay KB Adam tada ah c'est un
tail KP come home for me Kim Jong ho ho
hey hey goober so no tell me
I don't need him Troy Oh kreso toy a
initial release tell me okay you got
Steve yeah see ya
how do you say okay how do you say nice
to meet you
okay so kiss me now Champa Champa
Tony Tony - meow - oh absolutely
you know potent they were manny mota
troy Kumu aggy
Pam Bobby the money yummy no need to
call yo hago M de contaminate homework
yeah ed check out Tatiana
teacher oh yeah
how sweet Samira come on Giggy got audio
say again
my princess Alina the Cheerios hello
maybe she got yomo yomo is paying off
por tu carro tow get all trans all the
chicken Rocio
ah l1 oh no no there you go Raja well
well they some garden restaurant that
you my humble have oh yeah go get our Oh
Christian
yogi tea room Tong um how important yeah
justice funny so this whole spiel
ourselves painting and everything bro
sir
Spain
hey hey hey hey
well she was still talking what yo yo
magic kaito Picasso me oh hey there mm
Sahil
j-j-joey tanida yoga gee they saw
satsang not